So if there was a new request that is forming,
you know that the new request would have called the
lock algorithm. And if you call this lock algorithm, and
it actually executed this fetch and store operation, then you know
that this link is no longer going to be pointing
to me. But is going to be pointing to him,
right? And that's what this fetch and store would have
done. It is to give this new guy my coordinates, and
it'll also set the linked list to point to him
as the last requester. So that would have been accomplished
through this fetch-and-store. So what I have to do, when
I come in and try to unlock, that is, removing
me from the queue. Even though my next pointer is
nil, I cannot trust it entirely because it could be
a successor that is forming, it's just that it's not
that the formation of the list is not complete yet.
So what should I do? Well, remember when I told
you if I was the only guy, what I wanted to
do was to set this guy to nil to indicate
that there's no requesters after me. the, the list is empty.
But before I do that, I have to double check
if there is a request that is in the information. And,
in other words, I want to have an atomic ray of setting
this guy to nil, if in fact he's pointing to me.
And the invariant in this case, is that. If he's
pointing to me, I can set him to nil. If he's
not pointing to me, I cannot set him to nil
because he's pointing to somebody else. That's the invariant that I
should be looking for, so I need an atomic way
of checking for the that invariant. And the invariant is in
the form of a conditional, store operation. The conditional store being.
Do this store only if some condition is satisfied. Now in
this particular case, I'm going to tell you a primitive
that will be useful for this purpose. And that primitive
is what is called compare and swap. It takes three
arguements. The first two arguments is saying, here is L and
this is me. Check if these two are the same.
If these two are the same, then you set L
to the third argument. The third argument is what L
has to be set to if these two are the same.
That's where it's called compare and swap. You are
comparing the first two arguments, and if the first two
arguments happen to be equal, then we are saying set
the first argument to be equal to the third argument.
So that's the idea behind compare and swap. So,
essentially when I execute the compare and swap operation, on
L, me, and nil. What I'm telling is to, to
set this guy to nil if he's pointing to me.
If he is not pointing to me, don't do
that. So that's the idea behind compare and sway.